[Musique]
il ya toujours une grande conférence
cette année on a la présence assez
unique d'un chef multi étoilé qui en
plus a été vite prise hier pendant des
années on a aussi
à une soirée ciné débat cette année donc
on a choisi de de montrer le film hors
norme on a aussi le village des
mobilités
on a une grande exposition artistique
qu'on a appelé avec humour poubelle la
vie il y aura aussi ça c'est inédit pour
ponctuer la fin de cette séquence une
belle séance au théâtre avec des matchs
d'improvisation avec des équipes
internationales
[Musique]
c'est évidemment une
incitation de la mairie comment dire à
porter un regard sur les producteurs de
proximité pour essayer de d'acheter au
plus près pour essayer d essayer
d'inciter les vip revient à améliorer
leur bilan carbone par exemple le
village des mobilités dont je parlais
c'est évidemment au delà de l'aspect
festif de la parade vélo c'est
évidemment pour inciter là aussi les
huit revient à faire le choix des
mobilités douces quand ils le peuvent
[Musique]